I'm nervous do punch-drunk sportswear
winners win back in the studio we had a
lot of people last week not seems
somewhat empty we have kind of like
empty nest syndrome fight mommy's on her
way apparently but I guess you have a
kid it [ __ ] things up don't have
children you are right Erin how's it
going with you guys trying to conceive
not great you're taking our advice from
the show do you need any of us to step
in and bat cleanup for you can we do we
see some video no let's go to the clip
let's let's break down we'll be right
back after these messages
good how are you guys what's going on
we're just talking about before the show
this a 300 million dollar contract ten
years the Comedy Store or Friday and
Saturday so comes to me there and that's
about it right now what about you z-man
I'm at the Sycamore tavern tonight I'm
Mike Tolly show and pick up my album a
light guy named Chad wherever you get
albums a racist title did you almost
name it not a black guy named Chad black
Chad's it's a very white name - Chad
Ochocinco is the only so I was trying to
do a bid on that and then [ __ ]
Ochocinco ruined it Chad Johnson yeah 16
years yeah I know well I was thinking a
black guy's name Chad and I thought I
was in the clear until I realized Chad
Ochocinco you see just figured that's
the only black Chad that there is there
is
that's what the computers for guys
you're doing to or one and the following
to come up for myself
we're into coma coma comedy club on the
seventh and that is a nine o'clock show
the next day we're doing a four twenty
show but I know you should on Monday
that should just be your only day of
smoking weed hey don't forget the
February 28th show with Michael Rapaport
at the dojo Sycamore tavern Oh Chet Ryan
Sickler is he black or white regime'
with shad blackjack blackjack black chad
is in the studio today also if anybody's
listening to this live I think there's
still tickets available for Ahri's new
hour he's run it tonight in the main
room he's old rooms right in a row huh
he did last night was his storyteller
there's seven or eight year anniversary
or something like that
and then of course we weren't on that we
never will be and and then tonight he's
doing his hour special so if you're
around come get down I found some more
black Chad's okay and list the black
Chad Chad Johnson American football
player yeah we sent him Chad Dawson
apparently he's a professional boxer
he's uh he's black I don't count him why
he's Vox never heard of him no who else
that's two Chad Coleman he was in the
HBO crime series The Wire okay like
Dennis Cudi why he's related to black
Gary Coleman oh good probably yeah Chad
Lewis Wayne Lewis he played he was a
tight in and for the Phil
Elfi Eagles and st. Louis Rams Oh what
year is that
hi I'm talking I'm talking I'm talking
I'm talking just cut his mic me again
yeah why not why not why not why not I
can hear him dad Kinch he played for the
he played for the Carolina and the
Lakers so you know we've been pretty
ignorant about black chat holy [ __ ] look
I pulled my name look look on notable
Chad's
Chad sumac look at me Chad did that I'm
/ no look I googled black guys named
Chad and Chad Zuma came on the air right
there what did I say about you Chad
Anthony sumac an American comedian a
radio personality and your list under -
black Chad's and yet you call your album
a white guy named Chad Chad you can't
have it all okay you have a white album
and a black listing [ __ ] tired of it
I am getting greedy with that seems like
you are I have a funny story for you Sam
I love stories and you guys will all dig
this I'm very proud of what I've done
the other night at the comic store in
the back bar where the comics are at
it's like six or seven people in there
and I look over and I'm like [ __ ] man
that looks just like Sean Payton coach
of my second least favorite team the
Saints oh sure [ __ ] it was it was he in
the back bar kickin it him his wife and
his daughter both of them smoke shows
really and just good genes you can just
see it there at the Comedy Store
uh-huh last night no two night two or
three nights ago who were they a guest
of a parent Lea her daughter goes to
college out here and his mom and dad
were out here visiting her and he's good
friends with David Spade apparently
spades okay come by the store so he's
hanging in there I'm thinking man
everybody's all out and punky Johnson's
losing her mind cuz she's a giant Saints
fan and I'm thinking what am I gonna say
this bastard and I go hey I just want to
say you know I respect you as a coach
and all your accomplishments and you
know you paved the way for younger
coaches like Shawn McVeigh and all that
kind of stuff but as a Falcons fan I
gotta say [ __ ] the Saints and he goes he
goes like he laughed and then he goes
this guy's at the Taliban
that's good comeback like that I like
that that would have been great like
about 2002 I'm not gonna shake his hand
to be like oh yeah go Saints whatever I
respect that's like going hey run the
wishbone you know I'm saying yeah yeah
yeah dude you're in the house your mecha
Caliban she's it's ridiculous
oh it's a good story say Sam what team
you he asked you for oxycottons after no
no but he seemed like he cannot come
down Sam what team do you hate the most
like what's your most hated team dick of
all sports you have all sports yeah all
sports yeah god that's a great question
ah that [ __ ] bombs guys [ __ ] them I
mean I have three for sure all right who
are yours in no particular order
Patriots Saints Lakers I hate the
Patriots like I respect them I hate them
dude you can respect somebody you hate I
respectfully hate them
yeah respectfully hate them I hate them
I hate the Golden State Warriors right
now I hate down there pretty up there I
hate them um as a Cavs fan I really hate
them
who else baseball and I hate the Yankees
yeah do they do Yankees - I can't
disagree with any of those little baby
everyone's gonna be like you so you hate
winners no yeah I hate winners that buy
their franchises Allah the Lakers and
the Yankees naturally just because
rivalry reasons I hate the Saints and
the Patriots I'm just sick of and
they're notoriously don't Oreos for
cheating I mean like it's just weird
because I haven't always hated the
Warriors I just hate that they're on
this like winning spree streak and just
everything comes out roses yeah it's
like for this for this franchising
dynasty to happen okay all this crazy
she has to just line up it is a perfect
storm I mean every agent wouldn't want
to go there what free agent wouldn't
want to play and live in San Francisco
it's a beautiful part of the country
lotteries for a long time nobody wanted
to that's why I'm really laughing now
because in the ride it right in uh
they're talking like if if Kevin Durant
wins another one and then they go him
for four in a row you think he's gone uh
he'd be an idiot to let me just say this
he'd be an idiot to go tune to the next
you just be an idiot I mean like the
guy's gonna say that French has to be
someone like you're not even I on who
gets like drafted in there and changes
it up you know but it's like to go in
there when you've got this amazing thing
going on but they get Zion and Durant
that's possibility it is a possibility
but it's like you still a Dolan you
still have Dolan he's the worst yeah
every bad franchise has a [ __ ] owner
yeah and sometimes like franchise rise
above like so I was it Dolan to cuz the
Indians have Dolan's to yeah but I mean
like look at Chicago their owners kind
of [ __ ] weird right always husband
like he's like I mean like like they won
beasts are despite of him you know like
so it's just interesting to it's just
interesting I mean like Dolan's just a
piece of [ __ ] once again trust fund kid
yeah like Apatow yeah
call back come on dude what do you do
how you saved like chance I gotta do is
join money I'm gonna see that that video
chad sumac destroys Judd Apatow yeah
whenever you see somebody in the video
said destroy he did not nothing yeah
nothing now clickbait you did smack him
around a little bit though I I know but
there's no destroying going on you gave
him a spanking oh let's go to the phones
guys let's go to the phones we got a
call regards if we want it or not yeah
let's take it why not they were messing
up it's kind of a catchy tune
hi you're on wood punch young sports on
this crazy Tuesday what's going on I
have a question for you dude what why
were you why were you concerned trolling
Owen Benjamin oh I love this here we go
we were just talking sports Oni hung up
chicken [ __ ] no we zinged him let's call
him back well just a [ __ ] was that a
bear they should be called the parents I
know it'd be funny it's like we got like
a bunch of like like cold calls like
people just randomly calling like about
it like your insurance yeah yeah just
keep him on the line all the time yeah
we just don't prank calling people it's
so funny you just thought you try to
show a little love for somebody and then
they just they're so [ __ ] crazy
and call the White House you got that
number just call directly I would love
that show up with a gun locked up
[ __ ] Richard Nixon so you think that
guy's gonna report back to Owen like to
it I called it it was great right he's
watching call back in huh what we're
talking about so okay
return about franchise we hit we're done
about how can you save the Knicks the
Knicks in need they need to sell them
they need to sell them to somebody just
like what happened to the Warriors they
just got a guy who's smart and while he
hired Jared West you know that huh I
don't know why the Lakers didn't get
Jerry West
it's just egos man you know it's just
giant [ __ ] egos
I'm loving this crash and burn dude I
think to save a franchise you have to be
like as an owner you have to hire a
brilliant GM and just give him the reins
well that's what the Cleveland Browns
did with let me know when we need to
write a check and who to write it for
and how much stay out of the way get the
[ __ ] out of the way the Cleveland Browns
did that with John Dorsey cuz the the
owner we had a history like he was the
one who wanted Johnny Manziel and [ __ ]
up everything and finally said listen
we're gonna hire a football guy you stay
over there and we're gonna deal with it
over here now we're we're looking good
we're gonna go on into the 2019-20
season looking real good yeah and it is
signed what's his face we didn't see
that coming who cream huh yeah man
they didn't need them right cuz they had
on more than job job yeah it'll be a
huntin chub and chub will be get the
work load as long as the suspension runs
yeah but I mean you got him for nothing
well yeah I mean that's what happens
when you beat a girl up we get nothing
get it for free bargain yeah I mean I
don't think he beat her up I think she
learned a lesson
hable lesson about talking out of turn
and dating NFL players she did call him
the n-word though that's talking out of
turn yeah there's a place for that did
she actually say that allegedly I've
seen that use as an excuse when black
guys go crazy I'm people that's what
they say call me the n-word no he didn't
I mean she looked like she had it in her
that word
yeah yeah yeah how's that look like I'm
gonna say it I'll say it yeah yeah and
you're gonna get a smack into lady yeah
I mean dude dude just the whole thing's
crazy I mean like dude I mean football
players are crazy people did they get
hit all the time
oh yeah it's a it's a violent violent
sport have you seen that a speaking of
violent sport that Nick Bono kotti
documentary yet no but no pretty good
yeah I mean he what is it who is he you
know who he is no Nick Buoniconti yeah
played for the undefeated dolphins he
was like on inside the NFL for 22 years
both of his kids played football with
one kid got Chris oh yeah yeah yeah
and dude he is a shell of a man Nick
want Akane he's raised half a billion
dollars for this you know spinal cord
research that he's had a zillion
different lives and but he is just like
like he's forgetting when he's talking
he's CTE out the wazoo really oh it's
terrible to watch Wow if I was an NFL
player and I watched that documentary
I'd be automatically thinking how short
can I make my mark how can I make
maximum amount of money without playing
football for you call Barry Sanders baby
changed his family's life I mean like
that's what we do look at us dude
I mean like how's this story gonna
[ __ ] end I probably the gun in my
mouth I don't know about you guys he's
got cash you go along with the shakes
you know I'm saying yeah
that's true but I mean he is in the
middle of telling stories he'll just be
like I'm sorry I don't remember what I
was saying yeah dad I'm gonna die I'm
over stick a fork in me yeah probably
[ __ ] [ __ ] remember the Pam Pamela
Anderson Tommy Lee porno of course yeah
I actually auditioned for it but whole
time yeah
Britney furlong that's got to be one of
the greatest [ __ ] stories of all time
Britney furlong the crazy chick who used
to hang out the store yeah it was great
on Bynes it blew up yeah
and now our life's too easy on the eyes
how old is he she is she be 13 in two
years he rented that boat like him like
a yacht for the weekend and whatever
she's like you bought me I'm yacht and
he's like never really I just rented it
sure I her surprise that's how hot she
was that she just expects someone to
just do my her a 500 million dollar bill
was top-shelf dude there was no hotter
there was nobody hotter than her when
she was oh there's always some [ __ ]
third world check that I'm saying show
this should have been great
just because she's born in the wrong
[ __ ] area of the world no but at the
time when she came and did Home
Improvement it was on the cover of
Playboy like she was banging like early
early beats missionary to you porn is
female sports thoughts hmm hmm they do
need to stretch they can get injured I'm
gonna give it a yes thank you yes that's
your that's your sports they're
constantly in competition right and then
there's pros and then there's garbage
but everyone thinks they should be a pro
and they only have like a small window
where they're like you know in the
optical peak yeah
I mean there's some senior leagues too I
mean there's some chicks have been
boning forever and they just move into a
different niche some of them start
breaking down though yeah you know yeah
yeah yeah the wheels start falling off
them halfway through their [ __ ]
conversation they don't remember what it
falls off a lot of CTS I can see that
like even Peter North's like kind of
like cutting back on stuff he's like
yeah you know I'm getting old
yeah I can't be [ __ ] shooting these
loads for days young man's game ten
years three hundred million dollars what
would you do for that kind of money
that's the same the guy throughout
scenarios and I'll tell you once we yes
Francis and Ghana who gets to [ __ ]
hammer your butthole shut more only once
a week though and you can schedule it
around your schedule Oh No yeah I gotta
be honest with you man what about Bobby
what about Bobby leave you know I'm
never probably make that is still not
what three hundred million dollars was
like like 20 years ago not 20 years ago
if you're living in Omaha Nebraska you
are running [ __ ] right you own Omaha
yeah ah and you get it all upfront three
million dollars all up front yeah no
taxes no no taxes Wow and but there is
this world but then you're locked in for
10 years to whatever you commit to all
right so Bobby Lee once a week what
about Bobby Lee [ __ ] soon ask once a
week I think he's got a big dick for it
Bobby Lee you've seen his dick it looks
like a [ __ ] baby's thumb let's get
Bobby on the phone Bobby on the phone
Bob uh hello I'm Bobby Lee ha ha that's
all exactly like Thank You Man
close your eyes you dick washing today
thanks buddy I feel good
what about below somebody once a week
for 300 mil burn a million you suck a
dick once a week you could pick the dick
it doesn't have to be like some scummy
homeless dick like a regular night line
for a nice pristine dick like mine for
example I could never suck your dick for
a week let alone a 300 million dollar
once a week for a week that's sucky at
the whole week one time during the week
once a week what are we on a
construction site just making bats here
yeah welcome to punch me not listen to
the show before what do you think
there's structure to the [ __ ] of course
not
ah so yeah for sure for sure
you took a dick once a week yeah for how
long ten years for ten years once a week
yeah why not dude you tap out no I
[ __ ] i sir get three minutes put in
work
yep I'm innocent doesn't have to be good
dude I could rip dicks off there you
imagine how good you would get it by day
guys like if we're good we doesn't have
to do it anymore
well think about he's gonna be last and
longer now and you're gonna you know
it's gonna develop a rapport you know I
mean it's only has to be for three
minutes so if I come or I don't come
that's on me that's not you're doing
your job you're sucking me like sideways
like a harmonica you gotta swallow you
do yeah he doesn't so you won't [ __ ] for
instance and ganya I won't taking the
buck because I you know dude like some
about LA you're stuck in traffic you
just gotta take a [ __ ] suddenly and it
comes fast and I just think bad about
getting people blown out [ __ ] dude
you're done every game suck drive like
think I don't take in the ass I'm
surprised there's not more porta-potties
in West Hollywood yeah emergency [ __ ]
zone surprise chicks aren't just wearing
[ __ ] depends everywhere they go
most of the ones I date are yeah cuz you
date older yeah ladies 90s you know yeah
yeah I got some celebrity gay gossip if
you want to hear it of course we do
Chad so I told Sam in the parking lot
yesterday at the gym Owen to the gym
with Godfrey who's supposed to be here
today but he's I guess running late Wow
your first celebrity booking and you
she's on the pooch she's on black chat
time yeah so we met Fabio you know Fabio
yeah I do
I mean I posted a photo me and the goose
here I can't believe you're late you're
more later than black Chad we know what
this one would do for 300 minutes yeah
she's like blow everybody all the time
you just miss Chris Rock he was here
yeah yeah Chris Rock just left so Fabio
are you okay was hooking up with this
chick who used to date George Clooney
and she said that he's gay
who's gay Chad we're Clooney there's no
one he's gay yeah I've heard that too
really serious I thought that's like
everybody knows that I've never heard
that before I've heard that one I hear I
feel like everyone's gay though like
that's all you ever hear oh yeah dude I
like my dick sucker Tribble II was just
talking about how much it wants to suck
[ __ ] right before you walked a hundred
million dollars I'm a [ __ ] sucking
supers for three hundred mile and uh
three hundred million dollars once a
week he has a blow a guy for ten years
yeah I just feel like you know I do
we'll just get through this I just oh
it's just his finger once a week so yeah
I'd have to go back to drinking picked a
dick till it's great yeah that sounds
great
I'm doing it for way less than that I do
it for $30 I do it for minimum wage yeah
it reminds me of that I'm gonna give you
a check did you watch the fight we
haven't talked about it yet I did watch
you watch them there are some good
fights and finally I now know that you
broke down and got ESPN plus you did but
it's a $4 for month yeah that's too much
for my kind what I just I'm not
complaining about the price I'm
complaining about this motion to where
everything you do you have to pay for
you're going to pay to read sighs dude
it's it's that they're gonna do a fox it
they're gonna have fights on ESPN
they're also gonna have fights on Plus
yeah that's fine that's what they should
be but at first wasn't it just supposed
to be all Plus yeah this one was on
regular ESPN which I was like good which
is why I want he'll do that I don't see
them putting [ __ ] Kane and nagulu on
[ __ ] an app I just that's right
they're too big for that did you think
that was an early stoppage no he blues
Nia Jay did blows you know blue is
[ __ ] me up
this guy can't his body just can't take
it he's got the skills he just his body
can't take the training it's just like
whatever this is it's just it's his
body's not built for it
how long until Francis gets a title shot
didn't hear well stupid and it was bad
yeah yeah well you know my theory ESPN
wants all black champions I'm honestly
believe that he's 13 and 3 I think King
here's my problem with the UFC again is
like no no tune-up fights like you throw
cane in with this guy that's just a
sparking savage like it's like that's a
heavyweight division though yeah but
dude there's Kansas like listen a belt
or is can be a [ __ ] show sometimes they
had some good fights this weekend but
it's like they know how to bring
somebody back slowly boxing does it all
the time you give people tune-up fight
they do this to their they do it they
did to uh Conor McGregor with this last
fight they did it to Gregor really
needed a tuna fight to not fight and
then he did it to [ __ ] up the big guy
what's his name uh Brock Lesnar got
[ __ ] like three I'm cool with that
I'm cool with that his [ __ ] card out
of them he's like [ __ ] monster big
[ __ ] got three feet carved out of
your [ __ ] like a pumpkin yeah I guess
cleaning out the inside of a pumpkin I
just think they did that guy disservice
it's like dude that's a great brand and
you some what now his knees blown out
it's like God he's got weird tits
doesn't he I again I I think that he
could go down the 205 I mean I really do
believe that if you really go down the
205 you think he's like 250 I mean okay
maybe not to fight that's why they need
a division every ten pounds every ten
pounds they needed divisions Sam would
you blow him every day for one week for
300 million dollars every day for one
week I don't know every week I take that
every day for a week for three bucks
yeah there's a fine line between [ __ ]
gay and stupid I'd rather suck a dick
seven days in a row for 300 million then
every week for ten years yeah of course
cuz I'm gonna start getting feelings for
that guy if it's ten years well if he
can't show up he's sick not feeling good
you started taking it personal
yeah exactly like getting blown off you
guys are gonna get old
yeah we're gonna grow old together is
what we're gonna do
yeah and that dick won't be able to get
up so it's like is it me is it me yeah
you're gonna I'm [ __ ] therapy you're
like I'm just trying to pay off this
[ __ ] deal roofie in his coffee with
Viagra I'm surprised girls don't roofie
guys with Viagra more wives and [ __ ] why
so they don't feel bad I would be like
wow boners I still take boner pills I
love rocking boners yeah me time hard
right now yeah I'm trying to suck my own
dick for 300 Bobby yeah I'll just talk
about sucking [ __ ] Steinem affect me
that sweaters [ __ ] sucking dicks sure
is why do you think I got this I was
with Sam in 2010 in Cleveland when he
got roofied yeah I got roofie by this
chick because I was telling about how
she had such big tits so what'd she want
to do with you rape you know a Chad did
I woke up at his house with my pants
around my legs what's going on decided
sound pretty suspicious for a white chat
over here why Chad dude Sam was so out
of his mind he we were in the middle of
the bar he took off a shirt got on the
bar he was swinging the shirt there real
and then he fell over all the drinks
fell everywhere it was like a big scene
really yeah yeah you don't have any
recollection of it [ __ ] doing
Cleveland right that's what it is that's
how needed a [ __ ] wake up and Tripoli
started what happened after that Chad
[ __ ] the caps are going to the finals
right yeah you're a star [ __ ] change
in the town cuz [ __ ] blackout Tripoli
came in Cubs we know in the World Series
you two have a lot of stories about each
other that you guys can use against each
other I feel like oh yeah yeah just like
a team story I should check out the new
podcast bye Chad yeah we talked about
Dave wrath calling us nobody's honest
last you see uh my other manager yeah I
saw your tweet and I was
you see this floor it's knocking like
that dude there's a folder on my
computer says blackmail triply so I got
really so David Rath called you a nobody
called you nobodies well well he's right
about that
okay Schubert him I believe as well
right yeah but he apologizes Schubert
yeah
he's the only one he apologized in an
email thread with Jason Jimmy Schubert
nice nice so rude yeah it's so [ __ ]
rude um guys check out my special man
people are still talking about it it's
zero fox armageddon and it is live and
you get you can rent it or you can uh
you can buy it starring a nobody
starting a [ __ ] nobody
that should be your new that should be a
new special nobody nobody [ __ ] nobody
I'm gonna try to put [ __ ] every
produced by Dave we're just trying to
put out a story that's what he said it
was the other good fight that was on
that card I they had a chick fight that
was really good good yeah those girls
[ __ ] through dog I was a hot fight I
thought the other girl won though that's
my opinion
so did I they did their in north south
for a long time if you know what I mean
no I don't what does that mean
lightning cases well it looks like
they're 69 and like there's no
opposition they were in a position for
both of them will get enough [ __ ]
with if you know I'm saying well I
wonder if they do that they just [ __ ]
don't take care of the burger and just
go in there [ __ ] just ripe and ready
to rock I'm sorry
did you know I'm saying just a thought
tactic for what god of to [ __ ] yeah
just trash [ __ ] well I'd still
[ __ ] both over yeah dude I'm good
friends with Jess guy and like when
she's in that like in the ring she looks
like a monster but when she's like all
cleaned up woo she's a smoke Joe she
voted her best body in the UFC
2016 really yeah what blog [ __ ] hot
he's got a good body too she's okay
she's got a nice ass I think
but the best body is Jim Jessica and so
funny she's like fighting for a
championship already like she she got
her ass beat five in a row or she didn't
get her ass beat but she couldn't get
any um she didn't get into judges
decisions for a while
well yeah she killed it in Bellator then
she went over the UFC and had a rough go
of it with a couple decisions but now
she's turning it around yeah probably
how do you know her we're from the
Cleveland area oh I didn't know she was
from Cleveland yeah yeah we actually
girl she have a roofie Sam in Cleveland
hmm look into that you would remember
actually wouldn't I would you actually
wouldn't rob would was one of the last
of my really hard drinking days I heard
she allegedly banged Adam hunter anyways
keep going he's banged a lot of fighters
there's another one on that card the one
with all the tattoos Ashlee evans-smith
really yeah but he's done a lot of when
I was talking he's had he talks about on
his podcast okay before he was married
with the child he was a big UFC pounder
yeah he's like hey if you're my spar he
called it sparring yeah you up you wanna
roll I think you try it let me see your
button he might have told her I have
Chad sumac says rumors chad is [ __ ]
breaking all the news here gay Clooney
Chad's [ __ ] all the [ __ ] MMA gym
let's go to the phones you're testing
your tongue dude test just [ __ ] we
should take a call from Aaron our UFC
what else want any other good fights in
there on this I need uh that my name is
David I'm looking for a relationship it
varies like is that you Aaron you sound
like Josh Flagg's I did that is a good
job by your person let's see that's when
I [ __ ] it up yeah god damn it that's
what I used to do
Oh same guys do it thank you
take it calling hello keep his number up
there - hey hey Aaron don't hang up on
me don't hang up on the air and hang up
of you if you want to hang up we'll do
what we want so you're calling in saying
I i trolled i concern trolled oh it okay
well I asked you why well I I didn't
concern troll Owen because there's no
such thing as concern trolls okay that's
something a guy just says when he hasn't
had human condos debo okay so listen so
I got asked to defend Owen Benjamin
because he did does a song with the
n-word in it and all I ever said dude
was that Owens on his own path is gonna
do it
I know ton of comics who have the n-word
in their jokes I have it I have jokes
with the n-word in it the difference
between me and him is that I did make it
a First Amendment issue hints at him
singing a song like what the n-word in
it is no different than Kathy Griffin
holding up Trump's head day we did it to
get a reaction we didn't know it no it's
not it's not it's being done to get a
reaction and they got many people
support Owen then like what what are you
talking about if he's like this villain
well the biggest thing you know I'm not
talking like he's a villain dude I'm
talking about why what was the first
time see both times I discuss Owen is
after people have come to me to ask me
to help him and that's just a fact
whether you want to accept that or not
it's fine so I get a call alright so I
get call hey why don't you defend it on
our damn word and I said the same thing
just said to you Owens doing his own
thing second thing is the second but
after that when all I owned did his big
blog on me where he went off on me I
called him I called about 15 times 15
times I called him he wouldn't take my
call he bragged about it on his show he
bragged about how I kept calling him he
wouldn't [ __ ] answer me okay so then
I get a call from a bunch of people
who've been watching his videos and
whether you won't believe it or not
people were saying
me dude they're little concerned by him
i still get these [ __ ] calls their
little tax I'm still I'm concerned about
I'm concerned so I did the thing that
owned us which is make a video trying to
reach out to somebody okay I don't know
who how you were raised but men talk to
each other okay that's what we do I did
the thing at the end because they got
asked to do that I have an attack going
to let last [ __ ] video I just did
right there what cuz I'm just getting
[ __ ] people like you coming at me all
the time
I just mean I be like me yeah like you
I'm just asking a question
come on dude you're not asking a
question you're not asking a question
you know what to call it a talk sports
you're coming from a point of view dude
that is just like you obviously have
your opinion you've listened to this guy
say these things over and over again you
know you got to ask yourself if this
dude has problems with everybody maybe
the problem is him the common
denominator is him he didn't get ran out
of that Hollywood he didn't get ran out
he chose to leave and then scorch
everybody everybody who still gets along
with each other and he did you're
speaking in generalization no I'm not no
no no echo chamber no no we're talking
about all the people that own scorches
on his [ __ ] thing constantly look
who's here
I gotta give it up so that's what's
going on dude bro man talking job that's
go on this [ __ ] do a podcast or just
could be awful [ __ ] radio so no I've
known him for a while
I wanted to talk to him and it's done we
all move on ocaña no yes you guys were
good friends yeah I tried talking to
like people like Rogan no no and like
this what's that
cool buddy hey things are calling I'm
hanging up please welcome special guest
Hey Dude what's your name say your name
and what is your intent
Ari Shaffir I like sports
how are you are you good to see you dude
how's the hand buddy her just showing
great it's okay it was fun a lot of
drinking though it's a real cast you
really brothers it's not a real cast
like a little plaster oh [ __ ] him you're
going for that kind of like it's like
those NFL players that would have a
broken hand but then they would keep the
cast all year so it's / oh yeah it's
real bad Thanks happen I love those he
working on those little workarounds of
sports kind of like when they said they
weren't gonna play Anthony Davis and
like we'll find you a hundred thousand
dollars a game like okay we'll play them
always got a thing's got a pimple on his
back yeah that like he couldn't play was
a headache
of teeth yeah yeah of course of course
oh yeah what we talked about so far
today we talked about are the signing of
Machado ten years three entrees no one
suspected apologize socks are white sox
fans really thought they were gonna get
him the problem is he's a great player
but like he's not quite as great as like
everyone's like best in in a lifetime so
i just see him as an all-star comes good
but like just an all-star Colin Cowherd
it's like he's gonna fill the room I
know he's not gonna fill the room either
nobody's gonna child is playing let's go
it's like he said first couple weeks and
then it was just fades away fade away
exciting just because the big signing
but if you if you took us all away he's
like he's only been like famous for two
years yeah I mean like and dude he got
exposed when he was on the Dodgers he
didn't show up during the playoff run
and he has a shitty attitude man it's
about 300 with you know 110 under seven
RBI it's like good solid numbers but
it's not like [ __ ] yeah you know yeah
God God see what this guy would do for
the judge you get Aaron Judge you're
like oh [ __ ] you know yeah guys not on
that I don't know all right ask him so
this is what we've been doing 300
million dollars okay thank you for 10
years god I'm taking it what would you
do first for 300 million
here's where would you let Francis in
gone who [ __ ] you and he asked one so
weak and you got her ass word
room room that thing that thing all ashy
really yeah because it's peaceful big
yeah and his [ __ ] so small you ever
see yeah
you ever see a dog trying to fit through
a cat door a big dog yeah so then you're
gonna say no to the but [ __ ] by
Frances and Gandhi objects it's just not
a lot of room I'm just saying what does
the guy goes it's just the tip no no
he's gonna take a real pounding oh he's
gonna like a joy it but you hundred
million dollars is not he's not paying
me the money
nobody he's he gets a cut of something
else he's just doing it for the love of
the game he finishes fast to be honest
yeah under the most guys [ __ ] hits
ones every weekend once a week for 10
years I wouldn't do it can I pick the
day of the week I gotta be honest though
like after the first that's very fairly
I put the first how many once a week for
how long 10 years after the first 35
fucking's you're gonna start having
feelings yeah I would I know I'd see
that's my problem it loses its meaning
though it wouldn't be like oh no I go
too much or my big fear is that I would
I go to work do my big fear is that I
would get emotionally attached and then
I would just give the money back and
just do it for free
oh right do you ever see spr org what is
at cerustop prison break org it's what
the the website that got David Taylor
fired from his tech job we started
sending it around at his office what is
it I mean it's an anti prison rape web
site and there are so much like most web
sites are anti prisoners of two
survivors tales there's a poem if you
can find is hidden deep in that web site
called I believe called the number seven
let me ask you something yeah the amount
of traffic how many people there are
going to actually think about how
Stoppers rate how many people they are
going for a good jerk-off story
fifty-fifty Wow I think this is Johnny
Johnny's doing this going so they don't
think I'm important to the show uh-huh
guess what he's not I'm just gonna keep
calling in over and over again why does
it keep coming through the thing I'll
know and that song is haunting my
nightmare
okay anyway there's stuff about like
this guy got our prison and like he had
to tell his wife he's real built her
tell his wife you know that hey I need
to share something with you which goes
oh you're a punk I don't know what made
you some punk oh she said that it's not
if it's a tough situation be raped in
prison but the number seven was the
craziest one because number seven was
about the seventh guy in a gang rape who
raped him and that is when he started
having feelings this man was not like
the others when I turn he whispered and
said I'm sorry this will be over soon
well that's sweet that sounds like he
actually was kind of in it from the
start that's sweet it was sweet it yeah
maybe but it does show a lot of guys who
like didn't start out that way then I
start getting raped so much it kind of
started like it they figure out ways to
go back to prison
yeah walk man I got that free dick in
there yeah okay so then the other one so
if it's not in Ghana or some Australian
person is just gonna [ __ ] hammer you
before you the second one I would do
more for 300 million than what I would
do for a Klondike bar what do you do for
a 300 million start seeing people
stabbing their mothers oh definitely
kill my mother what about okay what
about Bobby Lee then folks oh yeah I
take that yes that's a shinobi cuz you
presented it as that if you start with
Bobby Lee I mean anybody think about it
you know first yeah and then it's like
oh maybe but I've seen Bobby's dick it's
here's why it's good not that it's not
very wide it's not I would like to see
your balls with Bobby Lee's dick that
would be that would look welcome to the
Freak Show
you know those weather balloons that I
go out of the stratosphere there was a
gigantic but that's what it would look
like would look like a little [ __ ]
basket in a gigantic balloon
he's got pointy dick - so would go in
faster oh my get [ __ ] switchblade
dick yeah that's what
need it for the for the hotdogs I need
to carve it i needa likes to use it to
use like swish and like and like Whittle
it to widdle the hot dog down a little
bit so here's hey Bobby didn't know no
brainer you probably do that for free
and you had the good angle on the hot
dog what was going what do you think the
problems were about couldn't get it in
yeah he can't take anything what
how was that thought for you do you
think about it at night did you ever
jerk off to that errand that's out there
in a lot of people's minds what since
you had the best angle it was it in
Sam's butt or was it just in between his
cheeks thank you god damn you Aaron this
controversy I shoved it in that they got
enough in for me to realize I don't like
doing this that's all I know
this to me this to me is like it's it's
already happened or it didn't happen
this to me is like when a college team
has to give up forfeit wins from nine
years ago they're like well we know who
won the game yeah sure okay on the
banners like there's no way Reggie Bush
did not win the hi okay you got a car
take the Heisman away like everybody got
a [ __ ] car in John's football in
college basketball also the car did stop
make him able to win the Heisman I was
like no you could run faster no she's
never here up baseball college baseball
players getting like Kart blonde honey
in there no because also they get
drafted in college yeah just like well
it's because I face balls like footballs
are so much been basketball there's so
much money in that sport Derek Jeter
went to Michigan for three months he
enrolled and then they're like fot sign
that the signing contract is like see
you goes I don't think he played a game
he went straight to the Yankees yeah you
don't even have to do the farm's I would
play baseball over football knowing
everything that we know now I sure sure
I don't know why just it's so dumb it's
so dumb dumb like your dude they're
willing to give him like insane money to
common twenty million or something like
you have to play what to play baseball
like they're breaking contracts
you're gonna break it 20 million yeah
yeah I think it was what no I need to
get black people like they're trying to
make versa racist [ __ ] and based away
they have plenty of black people thank
you play they can play they just choose
not to look at this guy a five-foot one
nine quarterbacks he go to the NFL think
it's slaughter do he wants to play and
he's gonna get drafted a now dude
ESPN is your student is full force to to
get him to go to mom no to get him to go
first round
who's gonna trap Oh perfect was the
first run I I could see him going to the
Giants no dude I think that Ohio State
guys go Giants
I could see that to tear Petula Samoan
polish so that guy's a good quarterback
here's a good quarterback which draft
pick is most likely to get catfished
this year it's gotta be anybody who's
deeply religious so could easily be
anybody on Utah they see the number one
religious guy's new wife who Tim Tebow
Tim Tebow is he married you just got
married
buddy finally get some [ __ ] then call
her up it's [ __ ] crazy I'll watch it
is she really
I figured what up I finally blew a load
pegging yeah he's gotta be pegging them
right I mean take a guy likes getting
packed yeah that guy who's been sucking
dick for 300 million do you I think he
makes the major leagues this year I
think yeah it would be interesting to
see him play some late season games in a
team that won't make the playoffs he was
doing pretty good in the minor leagues
yeah he's doing okay
okay bye he'll sell tickets let me see
Miss Universe good for him good for him
he's a good looking guy - yes he's got
pecs loves the Lord
ESPN loves the [ __ ] out of him he's like
a nobody wasn't even on an NFL roster
he's like a third stringer and they were
just showing him jogging in the rain
shirt off it's I he's naming on a team
look talk about this guy he looks like a
less [ __ ] Brendan Schaub
oh I'm sorry I said that wrong Brenna's
Gras
oh that is true yeah are you running
your hour tonight right yeah yeah store
what time is that is that sold out sold
out well then I take it back what I said
earlier do not come to this there'll be
some waitlist tickets if you guys want
to show up probably that's the opening
it's off right with so many notions
jam-packed last night I hope we still
tons of no-shows they were like we guess
let's Geordie sold out I'm gonna be
thirty people who don't know that wasn't
even a placement standing for your so a
killer covered no there was some in the
corner corners there were some seed so
that's when the [ __ ] door guys don't
sit people trying to make [ __ ] money
yeah that's what they're doing yeah so
how was all the stories I literally it
was great poppy and macho a little bit
but I couldn't see a fun show nine years
miss Pat went out first then run as easy
Ali Siddiq Joey Diaz Burke Chrysler
Brent cry souls yeah yeah I was great
man everybody killed it was such a fun
time we raised money for this [ __ ] kid
who got leukemia 11 grand oh nice yeah
making money dude three hundred million
dollars just give an IOU it is never
enough you could write that off dude
leukemia might move fast so you don't
know just try to hold off is there's
that bit of trouble with the banks and
the transfer you doing yeah thanks Jake
it should be in the mail I have you guys
seen how like every day every day
Wells Fargo went down for like a day and
now I guess Chase is like having some
problem what do you mean went down like
you can't access funds yeah they were
just shut down they wouldn't let you get
there [ __ ] you really Oh wonderful life
what I mean like dude at the meetings
what are they talking about
well here's what I'm saying maybe like
follow him with whose recovery and then
as he starts doing better but like hey
man that was a loan brother
yeah yeah just put some weird jargon in
the email who did this to you heretofore
things like that
I love it dude I love it
or did you watch the fights I do not
house your [ __ ] baby doing just take
them pacify her mouth and stick that
[ __ ] in let her [ __ ] milk it bro you
get that [ __ ] shallow mouth it's hot
sorry The Godfather Godfather means pimp
I'm willing to make that 10% hey your
baby's calling it sure does we have
never gotten this system right here Hey
consistent eight years of not being able
to figure out anything perfect toda was
the only place we had it good yeah they
always it was good when we were love it
yeah
oh love it's love it's that's where the
love is great except for fat man
couldn't sweat video still keeps going
around still keeps going around I love
it Oh keys popping up on YouTube on my
YouTube suggestions there's two things
that I see that I'm like I just know
they don't have it right how am i five
whatever like you told him to kill
himself my god that's just how we talk
you called him a fat man man called
batman' yeah what's up fat man hey
that's going that and I've been lately
been cut and called a child molester
because my friend is like a girl's
leadership you molested her daughter no
she was likeshe she she's a single mom
who had in vitro like baby and so I went
to pee and she was like hey I need you
let her watch you pee I don't want the
first dick to see for her to see is when
she's 16 oh this [ __ ] story again
yeah yeah she's like this is a story you
be darned dick right now so she doesn't
get surprised by it when she's 16 that's
not true at all that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard that is your foolish as
dumb mom
very weird
snow gullible and there's no thing about
me that believes that that's remotely
shut out them the last time you tried to
tell this story
Stano peed on you oh that was that right
you're in the middle of that story and
speaking of gullible uh Burke crystals
was losing his mind during that story
cry sure yeah he was losing his mind
during that story makes no sense because
he's a dad they've seen his dead hold on
are you telling me this is a real story
or is this your spin oh no it's a real
story hold what's wrong she's a girl
she's works in girls leadership she's a
PhD that's that multiple she's written
books on it I'm like have you I have you
Heiner daughter senior day on my dick
itself oh [ __ ] the first time you like
hook up with know that it's super
frightening like the internet isn't
gonna be even better by the time she's a
teenager that's a good point that's a
good point
like she will see one before she sees
well it got me hard
it got me hard so how do you play that
you got hard I missed the toilet I'd be
right above it that's the worshiper
nothing's worse than [ __ ] morning
wood Pete yeah cuz you gotta do angle no
I just stand on my head yeah you gotta
push that you right you got a lead for
blood whoa yeah I think that was might
be something else going on with that I
didn't know I got attendance so when
they do it you can't even take the call
oh yeah we can take when we took one
right when you got in we were just
wrapping Mona
so what do you think about the UFC and
their ability not to give tune-up fights
like they [ __ ] their best fighters who
with Brock lesner to get what can't
Conor McGregor they did what Cain
Velasquez it's like what a counter
McGregor when he went he was gone for
like two years went up behind him yeah
that's on him that's of him you're your
marquee guy what do you give some tomato
can to get back yeah boxing all the time
they did it with John Jones a while ago
I remember but if you like three or four
or five years ago but like if you are
the best and you it's all your
overcoming a massive injury you know
where it's like took two years ago backs
like let him tuned up because he's no
longer the name is still the number one
name it's down between me and Ari
BRR BRR BRR BRR is the best yeah let's
say bird took two years off right yeah
he wouldn't film a specialist first time
well no no but but but to go up and do
stand-up yeah would you put him behind
Joey Diaz I'm just fire rate went right
from the start
yeah that wouldn't matter to me to me I
wouldn't matter as much as this would
matter like you don't put them in a
[ __ ] theater you put them in the cut
the or or something you know how you do
that with that guy I mean how do you
have Connor do a smaller room I mean
yeah right yeah
you can't you would give them like a not
a can but like like so so this guy's
gonna have a massive fight some losers
gonna have a massive fighter in mid
level no Anthony Pettis type who matches
his skills more yeah and then if you
lose Nancy Pettis I mean I think that
give him a title shot I think after he
well after he fought Mayweather gave a
[ __ ] he didn't yeah he basically sucked
a dick for 150 million dollars it should
have been Diaz dry your child molest
it should have been Diaz trilogy and I'm
gonna taste it before I [ __ ] I clip
it out yeah hard dude that's I don't
believe the story but if you'd have been
like maybe smell a dick cuz you could
see one on the internet but you can't
smell it just like put it under your
nose like a cigar but everybody had
the moon not oh that's a good point oh
yeah yeah that's a good point
you know I think you did more damage
than good so she just watched you pee
and according to this story she tried to
touch it yeah with her mouth soft you've
got now that you pumped out a baby do a
disclaimer it is horrible
okay disclaimer we did it disclaimer
disclaimer all Latino people you should
not be a listen to this you can do
whatever you want with your kids we
don't kid scenario there are countries
worked legal to marry a baby
yeah good countries that I'm thinking
moving we should go that's how you cure
AIDS [ __ ] a virgin so all your
traveling has there been as a country
like okay this is where I'm moving to
when I quit you mean in terms of chicks
anything just like your overall love of
it there's a couple islands in Cambodia
or or or Indonesia that it's like this
might not be bad but I think honestly
could be Berlin yeah you really like to
probably like Berlin it sounded like
whatever that club you went to was just
insane it was insane what was insane
about it it was a movie version of a
night club it is what all movie version
night clubs were based on they have
these speakers that are only there's
like six of them in the world they're
made for that Club it is packed every
night no I'm sorry
Friday night starts at midnight it ends
Monday at 11:00 a.m.
Jesus and it never closes that
entitlement clothes you can go come back
only lose a show up at midnight you
start showing up at like 8:00 a.m. for
Saturday mornings with it no they don't
patterns they're mob so they don't watch
worse if they see you throw it's like no
you just wait in line for forever
this one same bouncer like a cover no
cover but the other is a cover I think
it's like 18 francs or something like
that
uh-uh marks whatever really no it's two
friends yeah it's about 15 bucks which
isn't bad but a lot of people just in
their drinking water
now did you being a Jew make it even
harder to get into this German club no I
got turned away the first time and then
I went back [ __ ] 14-hour buy all
German clothes did you avoid the showers
did you avoid the showers there's no
showers there my friend did tell me
about he was like just learn a few
German works we can pretend to talk to
each other
a wall yeah I think later let's go to
7-eleven like that you learn in German
so guys those guys are cool they get it
in a completely American accent yeah and
I walked in I told you about it like
this it was only two of us yeah how many
a hurry oh there's five of us there's
five of us I saw at some point I saw a
dude standing up hit he's like big
cubbyholes around a bar and it's like
you could sit no more late am I this guy
was standing up this chick was [ __ ]
just going to town on this dudes car oh
yeah just when I walked by and at this
point I've been there for seven eight
hours and I was like oh whatever you
know that's what gemenese were like all
the white chicks jumped on stage start
blowing 2 Live Crew right during their
show cuz it's like yeah whatever dude so
the first thing I saw we walked in they
put a sticker on your cell phone camera
if you take this off you're done forever
here doesn't this [ __ ] doesn't operate
if there's a cell phones out that's a
good idea
yeah so we walked in we said all the
people in leather that's how you get
into if you dress up gay you're it yeah
look like Rob Halford you're all you're
in so far I'm loving so it's just the
waiting room where they check their
[ __ ] with everybody there suck a dick
once a week for 10 years for 300 million
dollars most of them would for sure for
sure
the only people wouldn't was like I
don't want the evils of money yeah they
were like you know money so I tell you
when I saw at the bar I tell you this no
chick sucking dick so I'm like so that
was later so right away we see all these
people with leather checking and stuff
there's a story that somebody check
their [ __ ] into the [ __ ] coat check
it was like you wait here and he just
had to sit there in the coat check for
it seems boring for the most part anyway
so we're like overwhelmed me and
Henrique my [ __ ] promoter and we're
like and we're like let's go to the bar
the skater drink just downstairs before
we even go up how big a linen how bigger
the places you walk in the coat check
areas about the
Studios out there though half the lobby
out there okay so what point does blood
start shooting down and a black vampire
killer come in dude it's like that it's
that it's that kind of place
it's look it's exactly like that the
beginning of [ __ ] when Donal Logue
was there as a vampire getting killed by
Schneider Traci Lords remember that that
was her big like mainstream so we go to
order the beers the bar waiting for the
lady and I see this dude at the bar so
I'm at the end of the bar and it goes
long I see this dude kind of like mover
forward like this and he's got his hands
up to you know two beers and I looked
down and there's some God just trombone
him he's got no pants on or he's got
underwear around his knees and this
guy's just come behind him
kind of like kissing is like sorry to me
[Laughter]
trombone Ian what got you harder that or
the port four-year-old wine the [ __ ]
punch your dick dude I just so many jugs
there there was no I got in hard but
listen
so he's troubling him and then I'm like
that's crazy I took my friend look at
that I was like wow and then I was like
wait why is he moving forward the
trombone should push you back as the
fist hits your yeah that guy's probably
aggressively in that but no his his face
was on the side like right on our side
fists was gone Oh God shoving that in
dude that yes so this guy's playing
drama war through this guy's [ __ ] it
was even alive there was just hand only
I mean it was Damian really like he lost
his letters to make a mailbox right he's
just trying to get him out dude and then
the whole time the dude is getting
[ __ ] trombone and in order drink he's
still like I hope I hope they're both
for him okay I don't want this other guy
drinking a beer with his [ __ ] now
when you turn hand it was nice instead
of just one for me he's like let's wish
I'm gonna hook you up with a beer oh my
god America is so freeing and you go
there you know like we're in America can
a guy get fisted getting a trombone and
ordering drinks blocks off of the comics
trunk
part of the joke I do they shut down
this gay bar cuz somebody whipped it
dick out no way in West Hollywood
they've turned on themselves like on
sexual harassment updates themselves oh
wow
I don't know where you can get that it
is one of those things where the drugs
are flowing so much that they're like
cops like there's no violence
we're cool we're not looking into it so
for decades can you order drugs like at
the bar there's just people walking
around like you're joke
walking around exactly I know in the
bathroom and so you can like see
somebody's like oh you got like MDMA and
so that oh like ten bucks yeah sure our
drug legal MMA there they are
0:54 the seventy dude for sure is it's
it's everywhere and you see a bunch of
it'll just going under the water pot and
just drink I saw a lady next to me at
the urinal pissing into a wine glass so
wait it's like urinal urinal urinal wine
glass lady it was a trough it was a
trough oh okay okay and so she was like
she was being a little bit that's a
that's a lady I'm like why she's
reaching around filling up a wine glass
got a fish and harassment and then it's
same guys just the bartender upstairs
fist full of yen he's wearing a like a
you know those those things when you
barbecue what are they called yeah apron
whatever apron and uh like kind of thing
yeah coming for but he had no shirt on
over it under it I was like okay
whatever and then he turned I'm like oh
you have no clothes at all on didn't say
bar alright that's pretty much it's like
anything goes and who's the leader of
anything goes it's the gays did his
apron started tender with grinder
forefront of sexual expression did his
apron say fist the cook
[Laughter]
Berlin cheers let's make this a sitcom I
started with some pop Rosman
ecstasy that they don't they have em do
you maybe they'll show up at that old
school ecstasy Jonathan ecstasy then met
a friend he got me some some blow and
then something like slow dammit no but
you know what I'm there dude I'm already
on ecstasy what in Berlin yeah
is it good blow or is it like this it
was all mixed in they don't have any
Mexicans there the choppa yeah Berlin
it's gotta be good and then he was like
oh we have a good blow from an ethnic
can we ask that question we're all white
here that wasn't a guy whose whole job
was uh dealing uh during blow in China
is that true all the Nigerians is always
oh yeah dude like yeah I mean like
anywhere in the world Nigerians are the
[ __ ] drug dealers I get it I get it
yeah and then he was like oh hey this
time we're just we're gonna do just
ketamine so you don't want that to you
it was like well why not if you want so
yeah ketamine coke ecstasy MDMA
cigarette smoke a cartridge in a pear
tree yeah five golden rings hey just
checked everything off yeah you really
did yeah I feel the next day I felt fine
actually I went to sleep about level
woke up at like 6 p.m.
Phil's okay the day after that my back
was [ __ ] dog don't just jumping up
and down dancing for 11 hours oh I'd
love to watch techno Ari
oh yeah I let go I would go my 300
million dollars ari with the leather
straps should be a Netflix show do you
have an age you're gonna stop doing
drugs any tax nothing just the medical
advice so if you had a heart attack
would you stop but you're not a big drug
it's not like corporate I do it but not
like all the time yeah I mean he's like
a once you know yeah you're right if he
moves to Berlin he's a dead man for sure
and I'm thinking of moving there after
this for like a month or two really I
really I'm trying to justify my mind I
was like once I finish this special I'm
like can I justify going to Berlin and
building a new hour just and workout
sets in Berlin in front of cool [ __ ]
people
English speaking English yeah there's
[ __ ] where they come from all over
the world there too it's just cool hip
people yeah they all let's do in this
totally world
usually Germany I mean they learn it and
not like I've never met a Jew ever find
out how many people really died in the
Holocaust they probably all know right
they have numbers but I know when I
heard it was 13 it was three digits yeah
was it yeah for me 900 there's a lot of
dead people yeah it is I think was more
like 840 that seems more accurate to me
yeah but I'm again I don't know we're
joking I'm not a hug dad Amiga it's a
Holocaust denier for real for real
people get on about not putting enough
women at the Commodore and I agree he
doesn't book almost any women I really
hate him for that but I mean I've seen
entire lineups without a single woman
out there so you explained it I saw that
somebody commented on a comma stores
Instagram page just the lineup and some
Yahoo's like oh really only five girls
and Morty what dude my favorite Annie
Lederman like God didn't she's like what
are you saying we're all shitty then
like we're like we're not enough yeah oh
yeah what's wrong with just how about
celebrate dude I have my favorite post
of like last year was the World Series
of Poker spiral table and I go oh great
World Series of Poker at one source of
Poker [ __ ] it not a single woman and
only one ethnic person [ __ ] time to
get rid of you're always like you know
that's they just advanced they're like
[ __ ] them yeah massage I would like that
they would rather do that they just it's
all about equal outcome it's [ __ ]
hilarious dude it's like who do you take
off that line them and girls who get
really good they usually take off their
careers three to do the road that's what
that chick said like how come Whitney
Cummings only got three spots this month
but because when they come is called
there because it's really called it for
two and they're like hitter with a next
one hope it comes in yeah
they don't understand how it works and
another thing people don't factor in is
one women are completely not funny
they're you know we always kind of drop
that off but it is back to that there's
a bunch of unfunny chick yeah
but the other thing is when you look at
and I'm gonna talk about open MicroBot
people that could get spots uh-huh
people that are passed or what have you
thirty percent of comedians not even but
still 40 to 50 the Ryan stout put out
the best tweet he was like you know
women think equality is if uh a hundred
guys apply for arm spots and and 20
girls apply for a job and it's ten and
ten they see that even though right and
it's not even close to an eight special
[ __ ] privilege you know I mean I
guess yeah I mean date but the great
ones don't complain they just grind they
know someone's not going like how come I
couldn't yeah yeah yeah I mean everybody
did I mean even even to the extent of
like punky Johnson who's hilarious she
gets her regular spots and whenever she
calls in it's like oh the thing is since
there are so few women if you are check
you are getting spots yeah yeah I had
somebody complaining me once about they
were like hey here's a podcast to listen
to or maybe was a rundown it was like
this is someone they suggest is like
funny women I thought maybe they'd be
good for your show here's five names I
was like okay one name is Goldman that's
Gary Gulman that's a man and I've had
him on and he's killed one of these
women I don't know I look at her and
then two of these women have canceled on
me one the day of the show and you good
luck finding a replacement story on
someone who could do travel stories on
six hours notice and so it's not even a
regular stand-up show so it's like the
idea said why don't you have them say I
have them and they're not doing the work
some are and my crisp at is always great
yeah and then some are not and they
still want to be like well I'm at this
category so you should help me and it's
like [ __ ] do the work towards doing my
show he's a national headliner and other
people I'm too busy as a [ __ ] middle
act right right right look yeah I mean
that's when you call me I was like yeah
I'm too busy I love our people aren't
showing up I'm a gap too busy all right
how's the wrist now is it broke is it
the wrist that's broken or is it your
hand cuz they blowing cloth that you
just put on your your jerk-off hand now
that looks like what is really
original tunic yeah it looks like
something Jesus would wear around his
loins dude I went to where they buried
where they took Jesus off the cross and
washed him it was crazy I never went
when I was here before because the
Christian part of town it was nuts
people are crying they're rubbing down
the stone really yeah I wonder for my
dick on it so bad chaos chaos they they
were crying people that's where all the
stories
Robbi fake story started right now hole
right there is anybody there so emerge
like really I saw Tom Rhodes there I
just ran into him at the Church of the
Holy Sepulchre so just walking around a
corner and just like what do they have
like a crown of thorns or you could put
two beers in yeah but he goes I was
gonna get Simone I saw I was like oh
this is like a Samoan spot yeah that's
her Simone spot I was there and get him
a fridge magnet from like this place and
he goes for fresh mac go get him across
put it on this [ __ ] stone it's
supposed to like get powers in there I
was like we're gonna get across like
here he goes there's like 800 people out
there selling crosses without reason
alright it's gotta be like [ __ ]
knockoff shirts at a concert yeah
they're like how do a Boulevard when
it's raining and now everybody on the
street is selling umbrellas all of a
sudden and here's they're all knockoffs
it's just - no there's no authentic
crosses its just oh that's a cross now
my fingers I love the Bill Hicks bit
about that it's like why why do we wear
a cross like he died on that it's like
that's like Kennedy's walking around
with a [ __ ] rifle yeah yeah yeah who
is that uh uh guy what is that guy's
[ __ ] name I can't think of his name
I'll think about think about Jesus now
there's somebody they had somebody had a
joke dad uh where's like you know you do
this for the cross but they're like if
they hung Jesus all the Catholics would
be like going like this they were to
pray God whose joke was that not Yahoo
serious but it's somebody like that well
it's like no no but it's somebody that
saw who's serious yeah you know it would
like there's a guy earlier Billy
Connolly Max Headroom
it was Max Headroom yeah Max had
room if that was a weird show cuz it was
a weird time of television let's try
like sir I'm listening
about my daughter is a robot Vicki and
she you know just like I wonder if that
daughter robot seen a human dick before
is for how many white movies are gonna
win an Oscar this year I don't know the
fact that [ __ ] Black Panthers in the
top Christian Bale's gonna win such a
gar it was like it wasn't garbage movie
it was just not great it wasn't even the
best action it was a superhero was here
I bet that you can bet on these on Betty
so I believe you can decide for all your
bed needs go to bed DSi use the promo
code punch 25 and get [ __ ] $25 I bet
you can throw a parlay on Oscars oh for
sure yeah that'd be fun we're not going
with a host how crazy is that I don't
know how they're gonna do it no I know
how they're just gonna announce that
well they do it this year like last year
even with the host sometimes like please
welcome to announce the best male gasps
it is Steve Martin and there go okay
we're not gonna do any dumb monologue
opening [ __ ] about a four and a half
hour show who cares just got there were
no we just lost 10 Trump jokes that's
all we lost yeah and honestly whoever
did it was gonna have to be like woke
about Trump and have to do these like
serious asides instead of like just to
[ __ ] knock off you know movie
sketches yeah like Billy Crystal you
said yeah
I mean I thought dr. Kim would be great
that's it yeah yeah big enough but yeah
and he would be great so they got Black
Panther black Klansmen Bohemian Rhapsody
the Green Book Roma a star is born in
vice for Best Picture
so Roma has a chance cuz it's browns yes
what are the Browns they get down slowly
black hippy and Rhapsody no Bohemian
Robins got no chance go ahead it's about
a pause Oh wasn't that terrible Bohemian
Rhapsody I saw parts of it it didn't
look good look at what I made for TV
movie for sure for sure I mean you saw
it get your wine you know
and we're down the street the chat
boards are talking Oh what you've got
your wife pregnant I mean I finally he's
trying he's trying so hard and we've
offered to come watch tell me what he's
doing wrong yeah we can't [ __ ] play
my play I'll just hang out Mike jerk off
might not who are you are you just I
mean obviously if I'm wrong tell me I'm
wrong are you coming inside of her I'm
not is it plugged in of fertility
counseling suck when you see dumb
rappers knocking up everybody
that's what Juicy J says I [ __ ] mouths
you can't get a mouth pregnant yeah yeah
but Oscars are gonna be even [ __ ]
worse this year it's just like no used
to be such a big event and they ruined
it they ruined it with like we're doing
this wrong or this one a lien eight
everybody so only like gay movies
playing at the lamb leeuwin [ __ ]
Oscars that's the way it always was
though you get a great just fun good
movie and that can't win it's gotta be
like overcoming like it's got a slow
roll what's it like Indiana Jones
winning back in the day was in Star Wars
winning no but but Goodfellas was up
against like that's a good movie that
was up knowledge there was there was win
weird [ __ ] like Oh special effects in it
but they never get like best film all
those like has anything gotten worse
than movie comedies I mean they're just
so bad now movie comedies yeah they're
not I can't recall the last the last
great one I know topics under was
hilarious stepbrothers what step is
pretty good but yeah pretty good no the
best best one we're jackasses those were
like outside the what's all three we're
start to finish the funniest movies of
like of a five-year period
each one of them uh-huh those are good
but it's like yeah I mean like do you
hear Leslie's pissed that they're not
involving unless he's pissed I already
believe the story
buzzy Jones yeah someone who has just a
less sense of humor about everything I
cannot see I don't know why she's not
putting out specials I just don't know
why it's like
what are you doing you got your comment
what's up [ __ ] well she has Lenny mark
is writing forward like they're going
around he's opening go so we'll see
Erik Marino's not cutting it which looks
you're mad about what's your mad about
that that she's a killer comma no follow
you Leslie Jones is an education yeah
you got a [ __ ] work yeah I love her I
just don't know why she's not doing
specials it's like this you know you got
an opportunity you got cookies on us in
a long time it's tough to like to commit
when you can't really go on the road a
lot and I'm good movies and [ __ ] but
what were you saying she's mom she's mad
because the ghosts are the new
Ghostbusters isn't including the female
Ghostbuster because they're like they're
like ignoring that whole thing happened
and they're like is it a prequel also no
it's oh it's the next generation of
ghosts box yeah and they're like next
generation from the Bill Murray ones
yeah and not from Jude which he's
apparently in of course she's matched
it's a giant paycheck she's not getting
I don't know if it was on Ellen or what
show it was but they had the new
Ghostbusters with the old Ghostbusters
uh-huh and uh bill bill off Murray's
[ __ ] comment you just knew the movie
oh [ __ ] they already say he's like you
know you watch these girls they just
keep trying they just keep trying
he's like to say something positive yeah
they really tried hard they're in it
yeah Aaron an hour I was so far cause
you can tell he was like why are you
even doing this movie we nailed it
yeah yeah and then we milked it for one
more oh boy you don't on this movie - oh
I once saw the first ghostbusters eight
times yeah first one yeah second one was
whatever but the opening the second was
so realistic because the first one ended
him and Sigourney Weaver like go off in
the sunset there you know that worked
out and the second one opened with like
yeah we broke up he was a shitty
boyfriend yeah that's how it would be
you kept referring to me as the ball and
chain when we're at parties I hated it
yeah this is reality
yeah I like it those were great dude
yeah I don't know how you do anything
now I think what hangover might be the
last of the great number one we need a
female they will come up with that
right that one girls bragging about
sounds good how her
her Comedy Central show is all female
writers and at the end
oh yeah but we have two guys - what I'd
be so mad if I was one of those guys
like why not just say we have a ten
female writers yeah oh that's a tip tell
me the first letter and see if I can say
which will comic it was yeah because I
don't know what the shows are right now
but like what's the last movie you saw
at a theater okay
commander Bynes Linda seals Angela
Johnson and real-time texting me Oh a
walk off on us
a walk this asian chick awkwafina
awkwafina we re ibaka FINA that yeah
okay I think YouTube lady yeah yeah it's
fine
but it's it's ridiculous at the same
time I think we're gonna have all female
okay so you just said but also that why
did she hide the two boys yeah because
she needs someone to do the work because
they're the ones making jokes because
once again on period they need to have
one writer when they get notes they
don't start crying
it's so wrong I love it who are the two
boys
it's probably like [ __ ] aw aw just
pull up the water here aw aw oh okay W
aqua are you storming off because you
storming off Wow but we got a new team
with a penalty box before Legion of
skanks we got the penalty box going yeah
Chad [ __ ] says dumb [ __ ] we
we gotta find a lot of negative [ __ ]
about Chad I got a big argument with you
last week yeah guys all right they're
taping you can go to see geek seeking
for all of your ticketing needs that's
where I go to see geek I use a promo
code
punch punch drunk and get $10 off your
first ticket purchase we've got a lot of
tweets from people saying they've been
hooking up with tickets from us
sometimes I'll make a quick run to the
staple santa to watch a clipper game you
can get them for nothing now $8 $10 all
boom when I went and watch won the grace
heavyweight fights of all time boom
Sookie BAM that's how I do it dude I
love going to see live shows and I need
to do that more your music everything
yeah the sporting events boxing
everything's great yeah the forum is a
great place now so the green so green
let's you know it's a good deal red
let's you know you'll be crazy all right
yeah you keep fishing around there's
something better out there for you I
mean there's so much boxing now going on
at the forum what about comedy shows how
many shows anything can go anywhere you
can get comedy when you're big enough I
just saw Bert Kreischer shows I mean
that guy's at the forum
well we won't see Kiko weird City there
series directed by Adam Bernstein maybe
this in the show she's on uh Charlie
Sanders in Jordan be I mean you wanna go
see a weird City you can get tickets for
that uncie key sounds I can't I feel
like it's probably good tickets for
almost anything you know I was a live
event on C key well I did shrooms I
realize I'm doing well okay so all this
is good because a lot of people cry
untrue really oh yeah it's best to call
try crying shrooms you cried on shrooms
oh so many times I've heard that a lot
were there people who are not happy
sounds terrible you've never done
mushrooms no I haven't I was always
scared well because of my addictive
personality I don't want to get addicted
am Russian
sucking dick for shrimps nah he might
I'll do them on the show it depends like
half hour maybe oh so he can't go just
walk off ya heard your friend do that
he's on acid just walks off I mean he
did [ __ ] he went Albia classic was
asking about that the other day cos deal
bond yeah you went missing on salvia
sort of no we did it and he talked about
it on his storytelling show but he
didn't he mention my podcast so I'm
talked about in Canada when you
disappeared and they found you in like a
bathroom stall oh that was a [ __ ] the
whole city was looking for you yeah I
was just sleeping in a bathroom stall
rodeo he was like pissed what I'm taking
enough and they were like looking for
our Stampede buy your tickets on seeking
promo code cut shrunk punch-drunk get
$10 off I would go to a room that's a
free clipper ticket $10 off that's a
free ticket that's a free ticket dude
like a champion you're really uh really
looking for that huh yeah I have think
you're gonna be disappointed you're not
gonna know who these guys are
yeah it's not it's not up yet so there's
no like your socks are look like you got
those out of Berlin rave huh where guys
getting fisted in trombone what was that
yeah yours that's using that sound
that's Johnny blowing him up yeah he
loves attacks but you guys aren't
writers
it's an intern and a writer's assistant
we're on a 10-minute delay so you guys
talked about it earlier about baseball
and football players what do you think
we'll see another double sports star
like bo Jackson or Deion Sanders again I
think not because I think the the sports
organizations sports leagues and the
teams have too much money in it now and
they're like not allowed
they just won't allow
before it was like wow it's cool right
for him try but they won't let him play
pick-up basketball anymore you know I
mean that that [ __ ] is over just cuz of
money I watched that 34:30 on Deion
Sanders doing that and what I didn't
realize then and when he you know
because he would who was committed to
the Falcons and so he would stop
baseball when football would start and
then and then play football throughout
the season and then would go back to
baseball if you know and the Dodgers or
Dodgers the Braves were making a run and
they said damn we need you to come back
and play in the playoffs and no in World
Series and he did it without a contract
and just played yep Wow NLCS and World
Series Altima losing in the World Series
but he did not have a contract with the
Braves and it was like sure I'll do it
and still they [ __ ] on them for doing
that they're like oh you're doing this
for you and Nike gave him a million
dollars to just you know to promote that
kind of thing I mean it was so he did
get that and like oh he's just doing
this for his Nike contract like no you
asked me to come help batted like 433 in
the postseason
that's right eight stolen bases into two
series next level athlete man he was
bachelor like we haven't seen is the guy
man I'm hoping he's on the pills we'll
see I'm hoping he's on the ball they're
gonna send him to New York I'm telling
you right now I'm gonna be honest that
guy be getting rid of that Duke science
she did say in fairness that she was
like that was the intention to hire all
women it just happened to turn out that
way okay see that's all are you still
having [ __ ] skin in the game doesn't
want to piss off the comment I will
never do an episode of Aquafina I can
almost guarantee you yeah the thing why
why did you lose your show and all these
other guys are getting to do Netflix
shows I think I was the test case and
then they realize how bad they [ __ ] up
and then they're like oh we got a not do
that anymore
Monty bring it back they didn't go you
can't work for people who put pressure
on you to do the worst kind of work you
can't Oh Chad you learned something
today
veteran Jay guys first Annie oh this
weekend
yeah you got a standing orgasm this
weekend yeah good for you man I get too
dizzy to stand when I come back improv
thanks for everybody can't like people
standing out to dude they were leaving
they were leaving is guy he's got free
almost here he was supposed to be here I
don't know he's going to Germany by the
way I'll tell him about that Club is he
here for our last 20 minutes that's
black people time right there
you show up ah that's black porn star
Tony that's an Ellen Iverson time
Allen Iverson would show up to a shoe
the next day yeah I can see that you see
him at all shake him oh we have to talk
about the all-star game moment talk
about that how cool is to see Brad
Williams and Adam Ray out there that was
a lesson that was rad and Brad Williams
started and by way Brad Williams he
owned it like every time the camera is
on him he like took advantage of it -
yeah I mean he's a [ __ ] that's easy to
do I never knew that until I saw him
standing next to NBA players usually
sitting down when I see him I think but
yeah he's a little guy that's for sure
he is very little you know he's got big
dick how do I know that
by how much head he's got that true well
I think I've heard him on podcast
talking about his big dick I thought
that wasn't God give it up take it you
know yeah they gotta give you something
yeah it's like hey you don't have a lot
of this yeah that's how he got his ball
forget his one ball all right well it
could be worse I'll just have this
[ __ ] Bowie that just dangles in the
toilet that thing has to get wet when
you pitch it it does get wet a lot of
times the worst is public bathrooms yeah
it's like a Bowie gang does it ring -
ding-dong do you think that's why your
[ __ ] so blood cuz your ball is like
pulling ripping it apart oh yeah maybe
maybe it's from the wait do they have
nut reduction surgery
I mean we [ __ ] do your boobs yeah
yeah no I think should be against the
law not reduction yeah yes looking at
nut reduction surgery they did it
punky brewster they did that too I'm
sure it was like a breast implants I
think raising I think it's offensive
that we allow women to take these
god-given talents these big knockers and
[ __ ] slice them down it's like go
[ __ ] yourself you wouldn't say that
should be legal yeah it should be
illegal deal with hire some midgets to
carry your tits or how about a [ __ ]
back brace yeah how about you just lay
down lay down perfect
are you a tech guy no I'm up it goes
face it goes face ass tits but big tits
are pretty amazing yeah I go I go tits
okay
I said ball or does he I got tits [ __ ]
no eye contact and toddler okay I put
bar reduction surgery on the first thing
came up can the roundness of a nose be
reduced like I know who's doing the
[ __ ] yes sir scrotum reduction
beverly hills california press female
journalists or scrotum reduction so
should we do a kick started a fixture
not what he's rich he can afford it yeah
this is a kick starter maybe we could
get a sponsor [ __ ] off I haven't saw
your kid pay the [ __ ] bills then
we'll talk yeah maybe we could get a
sponsor to [ __ ] chop one of your
balls and oh yeah you abused that eleven
thousand dollars from the store last
night yeah yeah that interests them
Calvin Keith they've lost the money do
you teach your kid like trained it on a
lollipop and then move slowly move it to
a dick you know because the shaft
situation I'm really I'm glad that
someone is on come I'm uncomfortable
wait what happened what happened to Z
man did you just tweet something Z man
what are you doing
it's still on famous Chad I want to [ __ ]
a boy just once
I'm a country where it's legal I respect
the law
what a dick you can Selena black people
suck I can't believe it holy truth comes
out why cuz of what sweets yeah whoa you
really do those [ __ ] is somebody not
related to you what else did you talks
[Laughter]
are you saying that are you reading that
I favorite comics are you [ __ ] suck
ass Wow that's [ __ ] next-level good
one breather really good one
where's the good one oh it's better than
I want [ __ ] yeah read it read it
don't get like professional people
following this not my mom dad stop read
a breath called you nobody accepted what
else did you tweet bro freedom I deleted
him what read them what you don't think
Bert Kreischer belly box or the penalty
box
penalty box you only up here out of the
penalty box to read it get out of here
what else did you see that heat honestly
I'm jealous dudes I some tweets about
dudes I think it was something like I
hate black people stop [ __ ] our good
white women for real they're totally
untalented black dude
you get another standing up from black
people infidels kept tweets hey they
wouldn't have given you a standing
ovation if they knew how you really felt
if they read your Twitter I'm a [ __ ]
dick delete Brodie of course likes it
you got it
I also know him sure screenshot of it
before yeah we'd hold that over him
forever you know you could just make
tweets there's a site we can make tweets
look with having many retweets and likes
you want the best the best is this opens
up [ __ ] you laptop I saw I'm trying to
get into his Twitter on his phone and I
was like oh
cuz you weren't done typing yet oh and
then he goes I can't get log into the
internet oh so then when he got he went
right into a sweater news I know that's
why right held it for a while what Jeff
why are you live tweeting during the
show I never said dad I like
professional people follow me my plumber
follows me you okay Chad I hope none of
them are black cuz you said some
terrible [ __ ] so much your plane to
Cleveland improv again I'll be there
I'll be there alright how long you in
town bud I'm leaving tomorrow afternoon
afternoon huh yeah I'm gonna I got a
couple days I got Miami West Palm and
March and I got Tempe and Phoenix in
March oh I got to run on April what yeah
they did I'm gonna play it I'm worried
cuz you know that old was so [ __ ] bad
my anyone yeah so I'm hoping I don't
know why I was like I'll do one day it's
a couple hours away from West Palm let's
try it just Thursday Miami's a horrible
comedy town
johnny is doing a really good job in the
box actually sent more stats at home
than he does when he's [ __ ] melting
right now Johnny I was sad it's good job
the show goes man leave it you [ __ ]
you can you can reach we didn't say that
wasn't maybe yeah actually the rules are
you have to retweet it yeah that is
technically what the rule does yeah you
have to once you get [ __ ] bound you have
to actually retweet it how do you can
beat yourself yes oh yeah Johnny for
screenshotting it you'd get one dad free
get-out-of-jail-free card penalty box
yep Johnny can use his get out of
penalty box card for retweeting that my
mom fought us why are you talking from
the penalty but what's the cry guys
Johnny my mom fought a three year battle
in cancer I don't know what you have but
I hope you go through what she went
through double [ __ ] penalty box I'm
awful you just attacked a hero a real
here not robbing a gun short not like
one of these troops who were [ __ ]
cowards I mean a real hero performance
of the day I punched up Johnny Woodard
every night and that's including re
showing up with a broken wrist and Jesus
is shrouded against the [ __ ] Giants
bro
look at that dude how did you hurt it
ski and racing O'Neil and O'Neil also
broke his hand same hand I believe yeah
you're just some secret society [ __ ]
where y'all gotta break your [ __ ]
same arm that's I think it i think his
might be his right hand
yeah oh really I think that's a deal so
we were like we're like are we're going
to one of the last runs a day and we saw
this like you you just run but this
you'd go over and cut over to the other
mountain viateur like vomit to get over
this flat part and so I'm like alright
go like hard run hard and I don't want
to go in front because he has to stop
and I'm gonna keep going so I'm like
watching him to make sure he might have
a path for me so he's just bombing this
hill turns right where he goes to
straight and then all of a sudden I just
fall straight to the ground like like it
was a glitch in a [ __ ] video game
there was a rope that he couldn't see
that wrapped around him it didn't have
the pink [ __ ] ties on wrapped around
him I just yanked him doubt it the
friction tore his pants like written
burn wise and then shut with the [ __ ]
friction what yeah
oh it was great laughing so hard he
didn't get up like let me leisurely ski
over there [ __ ] laugh at him to his
face you know I mean cuz I care
[Laughter]
you are so I you're so evil I didn't do
it but I did you it's like 9/11 they
didn't plan it but once it happened they
could capitalize wait yeah now I have
two questions you say something funny
about what how did you guys clock your
speed odometers okay so now give
everybody speed and then save Rena zzs
for last O'Neil was really bombing it
the first day I think that's like 60 to
63 miles an hour that was [ __ ] goin
that s fast fast on skis I wish I could
have tried the hill that he got it on
because that was a good straight flat
hill I did try another one and it was
like a little shady so he couldn't
really see if it's ice and was scared I
got to like 46 then when I broke my arm
was at fifty three point two Wow yeah
and Louis's line were three and almost
as many as Jews died in the Holocaust
Weiss as many trying to do slow roll and
you [ __ ] putting that out there then
that'd be they're gonna block your
[ __ ] Oscar then when Aziz has got a
solid 31 what was quote crusher probably
45 yeah and then pressures got that
crazy [ __ ] southern man [ __ ] yeah I
think Marc Norma got a 12 so you latch
in and you go like this back and forth
like that yeah Oh Norman just went down
like bills that's how you stop stop as
we get down
he's like I'm loving this like mask I
don't own him very well he's a nice guy
you should have him in here it isn't
really nuts know about sports but he
really I was amazed at how tall Sam
Morrell is yeah he's probably 6 1 he's
no way taller now really I think he's
like 6 3 oh you should have him in here
here's a humungous Knicks fan yeah we'll
talk Johnny Starks forever
oh yeah for the old days you know hey
that I'm officially gonna do all these
old people it was great he was like I
paid like 800 bucks a week but he was
like got the interview start I love it I
love it oh cool man grandmomma
yeah katrell by the way to hear you and
Ovie's going after Rick Pitino what are
we going after trying to get them as a
coach okay that's a better going out
term what hold on you were you were
increasing your [ __ ] problems while
you were there it doesn't start it's
like the penalty box in hockey doesn't
start doing stoppages a play yeah we got
to fork it's just uncalled for just
called Johnnie's punch-drunk Twitter
hear and see what we've been posting up
very interesting
now did you watch a dunk contest I
watched some of it yes it has it's done
it's still fun but the heyday was when
brand-new ducks were being invented when
people were doing the blindfolds jumping
over stuff it's cool jumping over shacks
pretty impressive yeah a [ __ ]
leapfrog so what so what so it's
worthless
you know so what you all know it you're
like you all look I'll look at his hand
you did the same look you weren't like
huh you saw it you thought a little
disappointment here's the deal people
have been jumping over people for a
while
so it's not a new thing it's still cool
but it ain't new what do you think would
help it I think I know one go ahead okay
I think wild animal tax these guys have
to dunk why we release animals on time
similar to you what people seem really
worried about Chad defense you get Steph
Curry out there guarding these people
you can use either rim you have to like
make its dunk you can't just stop for a
while you got to beat a guy oh you had a
great one here that got totally
discarded just straight up
I love Trump
and I suck [ __ ] for real this is why
this is one of the Browns beat reporters
hey why delete like this guy is ya know
you got God and now you broke that guy
in here he's a guy with ethics wonderful
job re good ones but any other good one
the black one I think might have been
the best a little boy that also [ __ ] on
all well that one yeah that one seems to
have the most traction I want to [ __ ] a
boy just once and in a country where
it's legal I respect the law
I do not respect [ __ ] [ __ ] which are
all women the three-point contest was
exciting it kind of came down to the
wire because three-point guys there's
nothing new to do so it's like it always
wasn't saving the lineage from bird
hitting it on this [ __ ] hitting six
points on its final five to now is the
exact same so you don't have to do
anything well now the other thing where
you get the money ball rack and you can
put it wherever you want so all five
money balls on one rack so you can go
that's my sweet spot and it seems like
everybody's putting the money ball rack
last like I want to heat up and then
[ __ ] stroke five straight on I like I
mean the Skills Challenge can you I just
saw the highlights can you explain what
they were doing I just saw the last one
was that one guys behind he's got a hit
it's like it's kind of the it's kind of
like Isis training videos you remember
when they were doing that stuff you like
I auditioned for one does it goes both
ways though because the guy behind has
almost no chance no I think it goes both
ways yeah as you didn't watch I guess a
ball first and I do one then you get the
ball first and you do one right okay
okay so then it's like best or whatever
yeah cuz I like that that white boy won
the three-point shooting contest Kevin
Kevin Love he looks like yeah a little
bit like Kevin Love but that beard right
he lost there's another NBA player like
you know so in Trustees it's like
everybody's talking about how like
the Warriors like our people catching up
for them totally they they uh sure this
is like eight years into like gee I
don't know but those guys are still the
best of it uh-huh
they're the best of it I mean honestly
if not for Paul going down I think the
Rockets would have curry hit like his
last seven to advance like it looked
like he wasn't gonna advance and then he
hits like the rack rack rattled off the
board
dunno Turk what are you talkin jerk-off
hasn't jerked off us are you her no I
got it's rash in this hot tub we think
we all got Norman has did you call the
air binos Tennessee's got a staph
infection what the hell happened to you
guys in [ __ ] Utah did you tell the
air B&B Jeff said you were gonna report
it I did and I told everybody me like
you have medical stuff like I gotta find
it but I asked me to do a bunch of more
work but I told the guy he goes well
we've had no other complaints so I gotta
think it's only skin-to-skin contact I
know what you're implying that's not
what happened now you guys are [ __ ]
yeah but I was like but you didn't have
complaints um uh we were all in the hot
like I didn't know when his easy got a
staph infection until I just found out
so I'm like if you really want to know
you should call your other tenants and
see if they've had any problems and the
guy didn't write back to me and it's
like oh yeah I get it you're not really
a Christian yeah that guy's not getting
across from Jerusalem or wherever the
[ __ ] you were no dude look at the
frantic typing he's doing right now
Jin bombarded everybody please feel free
to bombard [ __ ] delete him feel free
to bombard zu mock sower Lonnie's racist
and sexist rants that are sure to get
him fired remember that time he called
in a shitty fire and said to how much he
hated black people find out the deal
went through some [ __ ] like that
Chet what some of the responses you get
you're out of the penalty box come on
back where some of them all new york
comics [ __ ] suck you want a piece of
me you
I never want to work in that shitty
state seekers black box cop bombs
they've kind of gone their way there's
other [ __ ] you can do to bother people
really he's good yeah
I find that one's good what else talk to
us what's going on what people saying oh
there's like a news article comedian in
hot water
chad sumac puncher i've investigated
[Laughter]
nice it's coming from this is like it's
like your fans are [ __ ] hey do the
best for your fans too buddy
they're your fans now welcome to hell
the Browns beat reporter ones bothering
me though okay cuz he's pointing out the
truth yeah he's like [ __ ] you are why
did you delete these I wanted on vid you
didn't wait three seconds to be like why
Oh Cleveland sucks to that I'm gonna get
mo as much as he loves Cleve oh yeah I
never want to go back to Cleveland what
else any other good ones any ladies
chiming in Johnny just won't let it go
he's just constantly like dude you got
it like he sees you gotta apologize to
it Chad you've never been more alive
than you are right now okay I gotta do a
bunch of written apologies yeah people
are putting trains like like it's all
over for me like a train wreck I mean I
think I feel like it's going pretty good
so far in the since deleted Twitter post
I always do it's deleted Chad do you i
text everybody I'm available for
interviews to discuss yeah yeah this guy
Q says it's confirmed that Chad sumac
does hate POC women and Jews Oh sad sad
I will really just live my tweet that
wow man
well what a great man one of the funnest
shows I've ever done in my life I was
supposed to leave early but this has
been so much fun when you're here it's a
solid I love being in here
like 11:55 look oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] hey you
made it Godfrey still not here how's
that booking going now we'll never get
them because you hate black people
Chad you go on radio today and tell me
calling your mom well yeah I gotta do a
little I'm going to Sirius XM urban view
this is not going to be a good look
you'll be just fine
let's call they're not even taking his
calls why Chad tries to save his are a
dead career you guys go check out
caveman coffee yes caveman coffees got
all the good stuff that's legal Under
the Sun you can go coffees teas um more
cheese more s'mores I chose cone I
stroked coffee you do it use the promo
code punch-drunk and you get 15% off
your first off your purchases like a
young Christian warrior great coffee oh
great now Kevin Brennan's wayne-o called
the voice of reason
I do love Kevin Brady hilarious on the
show what is what is Brennan brain it's
not that bad I know yeah this is my
favorite comics Ari Shaffir he's like I
thought it was jim Florentine oh that's
not that bad yeah you get a Kevin
Brennan tweet at you and it's just that
it's like you didn't see the other one
yeah do people love him in New York or
hate him it's both of him he does burn
bridges so it's like if you're willing
to be like you can Bert remember comedy
Batman that yeah so it's like if you
realized the kind just makes fun of
everybody so if he shits on you it's
like you know who cares it's me I'm then
you're fine
same thing with Kevin it's like if he
shits on you it's probably cuz you did
something wrong yeah it's okay
it's probably just I'm wrong we've just
saw it's a light Lincoln no big deal and
a lot of people like [ __ ] ham and it's
like all right Gary Goldman blocked him
cuz you know how he's giving out those
comedy tips yeah
so Kevin quotes sweet somebody goes he
goes what about the part of crowd
control Gary when you get belligerent at
the audience and
the waitresses when they're trying to do
their jobs so Gary blocked him hey uh I
guess
Neal Brennan's mad at [ __ ] Chad why
because I chat thinks because he goes on
Kevin Brennan show yeah cuz I asked Neil
to do was show in Santa Monica and he
goes you can't talk [ __ ] about me at the
Comedy Store and expect for spots not
gonna happen I've never seen a brother
he goes right at it it's not like this
fake Hollywood it looks like yeah I mean
whether or not you said it or not no I
did his mind you did and he's like bro I
not skirt and past that yeah no I know
the whole Brennan clan they're [ __ ]
real Irish man they are thought they
really are take any [ __ ] hahaha wait
you said a Comedy Store and then expect
to help do my spot yeah and I never said
a word bad thing about Neil ever let's
try you on that now with that try one
right now now that you've already been
banned never said you say that to him
just said yeah we were just texting back
and forth like I never said anything bad
about you kneeling he's like yeah
whatever dude don't lie you don't have
to lie cause there's a lot of people I
don't like either I go where's this
coming from
but first of all no hold on in fairness
you do have to lie cuz I try to get the
booking so line would be yeah I'm way to
get in there the only way I do will
disagree with Neil burning on that point
you do have to lie I think whatever said
about Neil Bryan's that his sketch show
destroyed Lob City that's the only thing
I've ever said about short Lob City yeah
that was the beginning the end of that
team
how's he playing on Detroit killin it
sometimes these guys just need a fresh
start
well there's nothing there's no good -
Ian he's not doing anything she's not
doing her potential know what she
accomplished she can't do it she's a
baby she can suck that dick okay she can
tilt her head back hello balls
run themselves over I do not endorse
this conversation
I don't endorse it either but I would
broach it okay fine open her mouth
stop I'm saying babies naturally when
you tilt them back Oh like that is their
mother yeah milk which is natural milk
yeah that's right no milk from their
mothers
protein protein
oh it's protein a protein oh maybe I'm
wrong maybe I'm not a scientist maybe
protein can't believe your daughters are
you doing girl-on-girl it's [ __ ]
crazy I know all these babies at sucking
tits none of them are sucking dicks come
on guys you should at least farmer out
for some tea makes me think being gay is
natural being straight is unnatural this
podcast brought to you by gay gay
everybody if you only [ __ ] yeah there's
so much gayness what's going on I see
joy yeah yeah here's another comment
that he got that seems pretty friendly
here I thought Chad was a stand-up guy
racist sure but now that he's trying to
[ __ ] boys I'm out kick him off the
number one podcast punch-drunk
oh man Chad this is good good girl honey
great job job dude look how great things
are going for our Kelly he's on
everybody's lips right now and Johnny
really didn't have much time to get that
maybe he's watching the stream but oh
yeah do you know what Ari like one time
I I was up for a radio gig in Chicago
he tweeted out all this [ __ ] like the
same thing you did oh is that when you
guys had your fight no no yeah go ahead
and then they did it like a little
background research and they're like
yeah we saw your tweets and stuff and
I'm like [ __ ] man because of this so I
that's why I'm freaking out Chad you
would have been doing radio in Chicago
you're on the number one sports podcast
right now and you're [ __ ] your racist
and yeah I mean like I did you a favor
you'd be freezing your balls off right
now you're in shorts and February do ya
all right I got one for David Taylor got
me in trouble just because he was like I
don't really have a Twitter you can
tweet this we were watching the Cowboys
Giants game and this guy just over the
middle just [ __ ] his black receiver
just like dropped on third and like
eight and just for a nine yard pass just
dropped it on a key drive and David said
I wonder I'm not gonna say it now but
David goes wonder how many times NFL
coaches just think the n-word and then I
tweeted that with the real word and then
it dropped off this commercial the moral
of the story yeah I had a big conundrum
right there cuz I thought but I was like
you know what I'll make a certain amount
of money being a free comic and I'll
lose money here there
say overall I'll make more money because
people come to me for like there's a lot
of homophobic racist people out there
that need a boy they have money too bro
we have money too they have money and
math problem people saw but if you do
that's okay if Chad sumac hates black
people he can hate I may disagree with
you right just tweet something but I
will defend to the death your right well
I'll just defend it a little bit I mean
if you avoid dude then I get somewhere
near our ease financial bracket before I
make these decisions please can i dude
we're helping you listen dude I know you
dude you'd sell out in a heartbeat you'd
be doing kid shows if you could we're
stopping that your real problem holding
you back is your name it's a dumb name
it's never let you go anywhere dude he's
one of the most famous Chad's in the
world corner with black Chad's yeah yeah
you're famous says those [ __ ] Chad's
it's won the election when Bush was
running oh hey guys it's great to have
already back it's always a pleasure -
when you say hanging Chad does that mean
you're trying to bring back slavery Oh
wrap it up good take care see you guys
soon suck it